il danse sur le parvis de la mairie de
Manil une flash mobble à première du
genre dans la commune proposé par un
animateur de la ville et pour se faire
ses danseurs d'un jour ont été avertis
via les réseaux
sociaux ça s'organise justement sur
YouTube sur Internet où on fait passer
les vidéos fait passer les messages bien
sûr et après justement c'est de boucher
à
oreille dit c'était l'occasion jamais
avec un temps pareil s'amuser oui moi
c'est elle qui m'a embarqué en fait qui
m'a obligé bien qu' fasse manie comme ça
ça fait connaître déjà la ville et le
principe super bien quoi parce que moi
je connaissais pas c'est David au début
il m'a dit flash c'est quoi ça il m'a
expliqué le principe et c'est super
sympa quoi en faire plus souvent même et
David prévoit une autre flash mob
l'année prochaine et il promè une plus
large
participation